si sono visti nazionalità e oggi faremo
una nuova challenge 24 ore super mega
epica innanzitutto ringraziamo perché se
lo avete consigliato a voi dopo aver
visto il video 24 ore 16 ed i 24
leggenda che vi è piaciuto tantissimo se
non lo avete ancora visto andate a
vederlo dopo qui in questa nuova
challenge problema tra le ci
trasformiamo in cibo no vecchietti
permetti mi dovevo fatto mamma e papà
adesso siamo già diventati enormi a noi
cara troppo divertente
questa e altre alla fine del video
dovrete votare se ho vinto io l'attuale
fosse la vita vitali mi metterò il
sondaggio qui e ora siete pronti alla
trasformazione lasciato un bel mi piace
prima che la trasformazione venga
completata e date le patatine i pop corn
e 32
mattia 85 82 per me io sono peggiore
anche un prodi della nostra giornata 24
ore dove chietti bruttissimi carico non
potremo fare le uniche cose che facciamo
ogni giorno come un pò vivere davvero
come digestivo
secondo te ci riusciremo e vuoi andare a
sanremo da vecchietti per 24 ore
[Musica]
allora prima cosa che dobbiamo fare da
un vecchietto e portare il mondo berlino
vuoi fare un gran casino porterebbe
berlina ha eroso episodio che urli
andiamo a berlino berlino da basso dove
il mio bastone o tirare munita berlino
si sta tutta ordinare berlino satinato
perché si sta utilizzando per chi lo
prendi la palla
berlino la palla piano non tirare
berlino non perché non seguire il gatto
l'arago identico in ora la vecchietta
molto bene anche bambino non tira chi va
piano va sano e va lontano e fortuna di
unico che avendo sto tirando troppo
povero merlina berlino sta portando a
spasso meglio ha detto berlino far
accasare vitale dai per li rendiamo sia
[Musica]
berlina che ha scacciato previa
figlio
[Musica]
[Risate]
arriva dopo lo studiolo dopo le forze
tra troppo vecchia le forze per tirare
la parrucca verde battesimo sferzate da
una molla per niente botte lusso di roma
lato incorrotta siamo cinque stazioni su
violenza sul tema le bombe o no parto
gli occhiali non vedo niente dobbiamo
ritrovarli dovuto caduta privati abbiamo
ne ha trovati di oggi schiacciati delle
opere specchi ma ci mettono paletti si
sono stanchissima dobbiamo riposarci ma
sarà la zuppa si trova attività fisica
per due vecchietti odiavo ci siamo
dimenticati di no straripò te
andiamo a vedere come sta un occhio
devo fare una cosa importantissima
[Musica]
destro quest'anno
non rompe le scatole gli anziani anche
tu sei a zero ma sono lo zucchero dentro
io debolissimo cosa stai facendo è morta
donna anita magari è vero non è un
turbante sarebbe capello tonalità di
questo fatto lascia mai dormire in pace
le azioni dobbiamo riposare e invece mi
sono staccata troppo oggi quindi devo
dormire ma non la vita di solo il loro
contorno sul coltivato city scudetto e
anche a faccia tra di scarico di acqua
sul volontario il divano aperta
aspettati trovata non regalo un regalo
si recavano l'ottima più addormentare ti
posso dare subito che nei campi di vita
preghiamo per te una nuova del piero no
meglio colui che hanno ben rompendo un
bastone in regalo un regalo che ti
riporto la giovinezza di quando eri
bella vedi tabella
ed anche questo regalo allora sono
proprio curioso di vederlo che a
svegliarlo per me è un regalo di una
sala di cioccolatini
non mi sembra che abbia proprio la forma
di una scatola di cioccolata perché
avere solo thomas ovvio
basta abusi le carte lo devi aprire
veniamo adesso gli occhiali si è messo
gli occhiali
[Musica]
la cia che cos'è la natura della donna
vedremo di grande era mutandoni della
nonna sono così ecco come hai
dimenticato c'è anche scritto e poi a
testare 90 e allora è il pensiero che
portano ad esso direbbe spezzetta no
anche offerte dei file
arrivai tutto il giorno così per la pace
[Musica]
l'artista infatti importante traguardo
al peggio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
più oro rosso
[Risate]
[Musica]
allora ragazzi
siccome vitale mi ha regalato dei
mutandoni giganti orrendi ho deciso di
vendicare moretti lo faccia juve
treccani la sua reazione provate a
indovinare vitae o regalino per te vivo
[Musica]
brega che saranno la materia che cos'è
la crediti deve vedere completa dio
allora questo legale per te e per
ringraziarti cuore perché legato il
bravo cappella era strano sentimento
allora puzza di sé le realtà giovane e
dinamica come gesto preso per te ma c'è
un aiutando il rivale destra del bastone
grande amore
ma che cos'è questa cosa
è un porto non è anche bello messina
catania
così abbiamo risolto un altro problema
e adesso colorado piegarmi addosso
[Musica]
mi sono dimenticate una cosa che cosa
mia nipote di re dei muse non è stata
chiusa è l'apatia nell'armadio qualche
suo nipote chiusa nell'armadio a casa ma
facciamo adesso vediamo speriamo che sia
ecco la viva e nipote andrea secondo te
viva bunker esordio ok ora scusate
scusami ma importa batteria mi servivano
per il telecomando casa andiamo a
parlare di vivere di scena a rimini tra
tanti avanti verso d'accordo ma poi se
non possiamo vedere la telenovelas pochi
minuti io vada
il telefilm dobbiamo stare studi file
cosa per la puntata di beautiful noi
guardiamo da un difetto non ne ho mai
fatto né pistoia lo affrontiamo perderlo
mi dispiace anna ti dovrei sacrificare
per biutiful però comunque mi prenderò
cura sul telo di preoccupare che lo stia
maggio robot dopo corsa se ritroviamo le
batterie ancorati fate ammorbidire va
bene allora è il momento di andare a
vedere la telenovelas e al gene a
dormire perché questa è stata la
giornata qualche cosa non vera
sono d'accordo andiamo la puntata di
dovrebbe zona e ce la fai ad arrivare
così piano piano è cominciata la sigla
chiama i bambini cammino del telefono ci
vuole regolare
non ci porta in scream e sul 5 non mi
dire che chi è stato c'è la pubblicità
di sopra il mio canale un attimo brigati
non vedi che stanno aspettando
allora se avete visto il video fino a
quella parola segreta del giorno è un
vecchietto rim bambino si riferisce
ovviamente cento è stato faticoso è per
i vecchietti per 24 anni
sapete questa carta e quindi bisogna
portare rispetto alle persone anziane
aree solitamente passateci i miei
commenti il momento che quasi divertito
proprio con troppi lasciateci il minuto
esatto così voi andremo a rivederli in
ridere un po divertiti davvero un sacco
a fare sti alcuni momenti della nato
dalla mente di legati in 2h giornate
miglio più diversificano i commenti il
vaso vi ringraziamo un sacco per averci
consigliato di fare questo video e se
continuate a consegnarci di touré e mei
commetti e ora vi lasciamo quindi per
vedere i nostri altri video è capito
quello che volevi il piane
noi forniamo no
a noi piace mentre stava andando a
guardare perché
[Musica]
arrivare